jetzt nähert sich bald der elfte
september 20 jahre und genau zum 20
jährigen jubiläum ist genau diese gruppe
die dann quasi damals mitverantwortlich
war zumindest teilweise für die
schlimmen ereignisse ist wieder zurück
an der macht und die art und weise wie
das jetzt so stattfindet nahezu kampflos
die übergabe das in die hände fallen
auch von verschiedensten modernen
militärischen material das ja gerade
bewusst der afghanischen armee zur
verfügung gestellt wurde und auch quasi
die hilflosigkeit in bezug auf diesen
vormarsch ist schon echt erschütternd
und das zeigt doch nur dass diese 20
jahre offenkundig sinnlos gewesen sind
deswegen ist es schon unterm strich
einer der größten niederlagen auch der
westlichen politik das muss man ganz
offen so sagen